delivery ticks it is greg ela here with
the lovely Staci Howard
hello I'm really not I'm really bad
hello guys
Wow hi American Hawaii thank you guys
for letting me know that I am an
annoying voice I do you have an annoying
voice that's what they said who's they
all your little fans on the last video
yeah what our subscribers said yes [ __ ]
you yeah they're totally right now like
I completely get it on your voice isn't
annoying
I wouldn't say your voice is annoying I
can never hear you I'm like ah oh it's
not like um what's that one guy that
plans the bird and Aladdin
what's his name Oh Godfrey got Joffrey
Gilbert Godfried geriatric 11 I mean I
wouldn't say you have like the best
phone sex voice that's true that's true
you hard we're gonna watch the kids
trailer today cuz I am Ninjago movie
trailer to pursue bring money later
gamez Camejo this weekend I love the
lego movie Lego Batman has like a really
high Ronny my baby Michael ate like 150
q % is way too hard I don't even think
mathematically that's possible
now the third one has to be the charm
because you know like first ones good
Lego Batman good now if this one sucks
lego ninjago everyone's gonna be like
you kill the franchise yeah so this one
has to be good so they can continue
doing sixteen more of these yes and now
space is huge in the lego ninjago series
yeah she plays with Legos all the time
yes most of her time with little
children yes I don't touch any of them
Stacy how away
I'm stuck I know you want me to save
myself so I promise I'll never forget
you is your promise come back
Oh trailer 4 trailer yet
[Music]
boy look cool now whoa really let me
accompany Jaco I'll be waiting
all right what was that last thing you
said what that last one we didn't catch
it
well I didn't say anything when you mean
I didn't what I said I'll be waiting and
then I stopped talking good
that's right your son and it's Roy no
hello Oh what mama you ruined my life
that's not true I haven't even been a
part of your life oh yeah it can slo-mo
the pump if you could need your fork
Jackie Chan are you ready to risk your
life but Ninjago yes I may be I know you
want me to save myself so I'll go now we
already promised you promised
[Music]
hello Lloyd Garmadon your son it's okay
Lloyd nobody's parents are perfect I
mean my mom is weird and collect
seashells your dad level cities and
attacks innocent people so they've all
got that cork you know Wow - Lego movies
in one yeah that movie looks [ __ ] fan
that looks like a field limit like great
time with the cinema definitely bring
your friends and your family with you
and again your own snacks and the giant
first you don't pay like $18 we're just
like some jujubes and some [ __ ]
popcorn with fake butter on it unless
anyway I went off on to you my word good
news is my science let it go everyone
want to go it just looks cute it's just
a cute little Velma
absolutely I completely agree with you
Stacy thank you in a review so this is
my review list that I got I see a lot of
trailers see a lot of trailers and I
think I feel like this is one of the
best shows I've seen a long time because
yes you get all the awesome design but
you also get like characters with humor
yeah I like the father-son relationship
like that back and forth they had at the
beginning of how his son wants to take
down his father but like the father is
so ignorant that he really didn't do a
thing cuz not even around
yeah I wasn't even here I didn't even do
anything new that the designs do look
awesome I love how we got the the lego
movie which has own world and then we
had the Lego Batman which is about the
Batman world this is like playing on the
Asian community world or I don't know
where the Ninjago I don't know where
that takes place I don't know what
specific Asian part it is before someone
harps on my ass everyone
give me Jeff Han Japan it could be like
most of it same jar in Tokyo or whatever
that kind of yeah here
it could be Filipino town near Glendale
but the characters look cool the action
sequences look really cool every year
right he said Pacific Rim earlier they
done yeah does feel really or like
transformers tasks as well like whatnot
little look like a Dinobot yeah a little
like dragon thing woo leaving on some of
the scenes now - performers we go movie
one yeah but yeah I think it would
totally work because the whole thing
with stood like the Transformers movie
now that I have an issue with it's like
they sucked all the humor out of there
but like the right kind of humor us like
poop jokes and pee jokes whatever this
would be funny if it was transformers in
the simplistic storyline and drug like
good rhyming like this was like the one
thing I love about this is that the
animation we expect great animation yeah
yeah we so deliver on that and they are
they seem to be so funny the action
seems to be really cool too like this is
a full-blown awesome movie Legos have
never been cooler they make me want to
play the Legos why don't happen if one
of these Lego characters stepped on a
lego you don't like how stepping on a
line goes like the worst game you can
feel yeah what if a Lego character in
this movie stepped on the Lego they're
like oh gosh [ __ ] psycho well that
would be relatable yes
however wouldn't just attach the foot I
don't know it depends on what and you
step on what are the rules of the label
Universal rules of this you know I don't
know like they're physics okay there's a
lot of complications I think it'd be
cool to cross over all these into one
super insane mashup whoa it's like when
you take Lego set and combine them all
into one thing even though they're not
meant to go together and you create one
conglomerate giant like super city [ __ ]
you hear that ringing Hollywood its
Hollywood on the phone yes I will
health benefits waffles all of all all
the great things we read each other well
on that we're ready we get your baguette
or get back before
nice banter nice bathroom nice I like to
credit ourselves when we have a good
batcher
yes yes perfected this guy's afro spree
sweet I could grow an afro like I'm glad
you can't you got a ball Yuman man well
my hair's no I have a hat on but my hair
is actually naturally really curly yes I
concur in texture but yeah good afro
like that I really I might do it geez
but grow it and then shave it off and
make a wig and then we can pop it off
just like oh ha ha
Olivia Munn's in here Jackie Chan David
dave Franco okay is Willie one boy just
Oh
date Franco's so funny he's super funny
I don't really care for him in dramas
but he's in comedy I think it'll arias
nailed it Justin Theroux nice Jennifer
Aniston's beau Michael Pena Michael Pena
are bodacious everybody recognizes
alright yeah that's probably to get
another great film with two Lego movies
in one year if so much than my little
child heart can almost not take it I
can't wait till we're at the point when
people are like I'm sick of these
[ __ ] legs on the sequel [ __ ] stuff
a lot of jobs like a childlike wonder
please why don't they do dis movie with
like transformers and all there was in
command and they'll be like okay yeah no
we're doing it I already wrote the
script and I talked to Hollywood a long
time ago yes alright guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejection yeah Stacy Howard well
there's several things about Spacek
she's on this segment 6° a feature film
on hit or miss movies channel yeah she
is also X Oh our 2012 by 2012 I've said
the year I created the account very
meaningful on the CRI my year of school
plant my before she call it yeah bad
judge of the string or not if it is yeah
Polly over there on Twitter Instagram
you get yellow by the
n3 I'm at CCO Howard it's a different
name I should have made in the same name
I didn't sorry dad it happens and make
sure to keep a lookout for when her and
I well me somehow this properly for what
John and Greg and Stacy and Brienne
verse each other on the movie oh it's
going now [ __ ] yeah and if we
win we're having an orgy if we lose they
get a watch John and I have that oh
that's gonna be great it's gonna be so
good for everyone
lots of thing everyone wins lots of
fingers not on a higher Nicholas happy
kids review be